could we be any more casual hi guys
welcome to this video it's gonna change
your life my name is grace Helbig one of
those things is true so I'm trying to
think of what I want to do for a video
today and I realized that I haven't made
a favorites video in so long because I
don't know why so these are just some
things that I think are very cool take
it or leave it but do not actually take
it from me don't show up here let's get
into it first mask you see a key see a
can you say yeah this was given to me
during my England book tour it is a
French Bulldog whose cranium is cut open
in order to put toothbrushes in I assume
maybe it's a bass bass a boss what did I
actually say and why did I say it like
that I'm using this for toothbrushes so
that my toothbrush does have a place
instead of just laying flat on my
counter creating that weird scum like
dead body outline around the brush
itself how wide and how this makes it
cute and also the Bulldog looks slightly
possessed which makes me think I should
be obsessed with brushing my teeth the
brain works in mysterious ways
next see see see a key say I saw these
are perfumes by Elizabeth and James
which is mary-kate and Ashley Olsen's
company the company is named after their
other siblings Elizabeth and James
talking about donating their charity
right girls
these cents came together and I bought
them in the little Travel section area
of danger when you're paying at Sephora
they're called Elizabeth and James
Nirvana its Nirvana black and Nirvana
white I guess the idea is that you
so that a man can wear one and a woman
can wear one I like both of these scents
I think they don't smell like soap and
I'm on board next that he's yeah he's
yeah yeah this favorite is twofold
one I got it at H&M calm in their new
home section which I highly recommend
they have a ton of fruit for your home
decor that's super cheap Oh 14.95 but
the second part of this is that gold is
one of my favorites so much so that I
fought cold spray paint and have been
spray-painting things gold that are not
gold whoa this used to be black and this
used to be pink and now it's gold so
there's that next this piece yes yeah
yeah this is um this is a Kardashian
beauty product it is okay it is this is
a lip lacquer this color is called love
hangover which does not describe the
color at all it's kind of like a rose
gold color I have it on my lips right
now feel like it's a slightly more
serious tone of the color it looks like
that it looks like a dog wiener and it
smells really good like the Kardashians
not the worst Bruce please just hang out
with me next then if you see Santa top
this is a Nastasia brow Wiz if you watch
any of Ingrid Nilsen or missglamorazzi
videos she is obsessed with this eyebrow
pencil and I finally went and bought one
and yeah it makes all the sense I did my
eyebrows with it today it's got a little
spooley which is basically like a tiny
eyebrow brush I didn't brush your
eyebrows sometimes
realize that that's like a thing that we
do as humans it comes in like a
bazillion colors which you didn't
realize that your eyebrows could be so
many different shades good luck trying
to figure out which is yours I made a
lucky guess I think I don't even know if
this is correct but I'm pretending it is
until a makeup artist very much informs
me otherwise next oh Jesus Christ
life sucks this UCF's yeah he said I
personal college and gold powder eye
masks when DJ Diaz who does my hair gave
to me she got them at a beauty supply
store but you can find very similar
products at Sephora I know support makes
their own brand it's like a gelatin
thing that you put under your eyes and
she has informed me that it's best to
put these in the refrigerator so they're
cold and so when you have had a late
night of partying or crying partying
what I prefer is just crying openly at a
party making it not a fun time for
anyone involved these are great the
morning-after there you go there are my
favorites for the month of January 2015
I hope what this was at all entertaining
or interesting or this just distracts
you from five minutes of thinking about
all that terrible in your life now it's
back sorry guys I did what I could don't
forget to subscribe and like the video
and leave a comment and all of the other
things
I don't know I just I don't know I like
it it's slightly more masculine which is
what I like incense for my lady person
Oh